c'est la première journée je pense que
c'est important qu'ils reviennent un peu
à l'école même si c'est que pour deux
semaines mais pour reprendre un peu un
rythme revoir aussi des autres enfants
et piétons contact pendant une structure
ça c'est important
ça s'est passé très bien j'avais juste
la maîtresse cavell masque
du coup on n'entendait pas très bien
j'avais juste ça qu'ils ne le dérangeait
et puis après c'était tout qui était
cool je pense que c'est quelque chose de
très bien
il faut que tous les enfants puissent
retrouver le cadre de l'école et
participer aux derniers dernier dans
l'hérault revoir pour les vacances et
j'ai retrouvé plein d'amis et c'est
super content de retrouver l'école et
après et j'ai joué à cha cha ombre
c'était bien
c'est bien pour lui d'avoir appris
l'école je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
trois mois en confinement là ça commence
à peser lourd et du coup on
vous lui remettez à l'école